Frederick douglass gave a speech in 1875
that gives us a question that we might
keep in mind right through
the end of the course.
Let's call this Douglas question.
It's the speech he gives
an 1875 in Washington,
D c not the year.
It's 1875 he's anticipating it's the
4th of July and he's anticipating the
coming year of the u s centennial of
independence and he knows there's going to
be a big national
celebration and it will be,
and I'll say something
more on that next week,
Philadelphia put on an
extraordinary exhibition,
the nearly one 10th of the
American people visited,
but Douglas is anticipating this national
centennial 10 years after the civil
war, and he's worried. He said,
the nation of quote,
when I'm quoting him with lift to the sky,
it's million voices in one grand.
Centennial,
Hosanna of peace and goodwill to all the
white race from golf to lakes and from
sea to sea.
And as a black citizen,
he dreaded the day. He
said, listen to his words,
it's one of them was racialized speech.
This is Douglas ever game. He stayed,
he dreaded the day when his words,
this great white race
has renewed it's vows,
the patriotism and flowed back
into it's a custom channels.
He was proud,
he said to be an American,
but he was worried.
And then he ended with this question,
if war among the whites brought
peace and liberty to blacks,
what will peace among the whites bring?
Okay,
what would peace among the white brain.
Okay.
It's a way of shaping an overall question
in Douglas and did it for us as to how
and why reconstruction ended up eroding
collapsing if you want failing as some
say ending.
Now,
one of the things we're going to begin
to examine today and the rest of the
course is this question,
sorry to keep putting the uh,
outline back up.
But we are always as historians
debating this question of ends.
When did reconstruction and uh,
there's, we'll see in a moment,
many are going to claim it's all
over when they pass a 15th amendment.
It's what Horace Greeley said.
That's 1870.
And then there are those
who argue reconstruction.
Now it really ended in 1873.
And the reasons you argue
that the horrifying Colfax
massacre and Louisiana on
Easter Sunday,
April 14th,
1873 the largest domestic murder,
collective mass murder and all
of American history until nine 11
okay.
And the following Supreme Court decision
based upon the investigation of that
massacre, and I'm going to
deal with Colfax next Tuesday.
Okay.
Some would argue that really
shows us an under reconstruction,
but all the southern states weren't yet
back under the control of the Democratic
Party. So those who are arguing, no, no,
no reconstruction doesn't really end
until you have the full redemption by the
southern Democrats have
their state governments,
which doesn't occur until the disputed
election of 1876 and it's compromise of
1877 and we'll deal with
that and a week and a half.
But then there are plenty of others now
who argued no, no, no reconstruction.
Never really ended in the 19th century.
Heather Cox Richardson has a book out now,
but about the story of reconstruction
and its issues moving west in the United
States throughout the
rest of the 19th century.
Yeah.
Steve Prince,
one of your teaching assistants has a
chapter in his dissertation and titled The
ends of Reconstruction.
He's playing off that irony or
that pun of when did it end?
Did it ever end?
Okay.
Sam Shaffer is going to argue it didn't
end until 1912 and his dissertation,
I got another, uh, graduate
student, Owen Williams,
who's writing a dissertation on the
Reconstruction Supreme Court and he's
arguing that absolutely ended in 1873.
This is the sort of inside baseball
that historians love to play mean your
Dayton and fight over it.
We tell the world dates don't matter
and we love to fight over them.
Yeah,
I'm probably going to
do what I usually do,
which is leave you with a good
deal of ambiguity about that.
In some ways,
reconstruction has never ended.
Now think with me for a moment though,
back on the ground in the south,
uh,
about this question of the
real lives of the Freedman,
the Trans formations to
New Labor arrangements,
this vexing, naughty, chaotic, uh,
in some ways,
terrible process by which slave labor
converted to free labor and ultimately
into sharecropping as a system.
In which approximately 80% of all the
Friedman found themselves essentially
myered in as early as the late 1860s and
surely by the 1870s and throughout the
rest of that century.
Okay.
One of the greatest memoirs we have,
it's an odd kind of memoir,
but one of the greatest memoirs
we have by a sharecropper,
and I don't know if you've
ever read this book,
and of course it gets widely taught
often an African American history courses
is the autobiography
of Neat Shark.
All old gods dangerous. His real
name was ned cob. Name was changed,
I guess to protect him in the title.
It's an extraordinary series of
hundreds of hours of interviews. Uh,
the Ted Rosengarten did with
him some 25 years ago. Now,
Ned Cobb lived a very, very long life
and in the middle of the 20th century.
But he grew up a sharecropper and there
are a thousand nuggets of wisdom or the
secrets from his past
as he often calls him,
that Ned carb Shaw has to give us.
There's this honest section about how
he never got an education and now he
resents that he never got an education
and how he resents actually it his father
never even sought to help
get him an education.
I didn't never get out of the first
reader, got no education to speak of.
And another hurt addition to that
weren't no colored schools through here.
And this is central
Alabama worth no count.
You might find a school close to town
somewhere that accommodated the colored.
And if you did, you'd doing,
you were doing well, said Ned.
My daddy when he had the opportunity,
never did send me to school
long enough to learn to read.
If you send his children, he'd have
to supplement the teacher's salary.
But if he don't, but if he don't send
his children, it don't cost him nothing.
And there's nothing said.
None of my brothers and sisters,
not one by name,
got a good book learning and all I can do,
I can put down on papers,
some little old figures,
but I can add them up.
Well,
ned went on to be a
a landowner and one of the most moving
passages in this book comes toward the
end when he buys his first mule,
when he puts his first stinking
smelly mule and his own stable.
It's like a religious experience.
Smelling a mule is not exactly my
idea of of religious experience,
but it was to ned.
But he really is hard on his father.
It's an honest,
honest illustration.
I've heard the sons and daughters of
the freedmen and now it is the son of a
former slave
we're inheriting so little.
I mentioned the other day
that what the Friedman had
was some human capital,
their skills, their bodies,
their labor, their dreams, their religion,
their ideas, their self
worth, the dignity.
But they had so little physical capital,
they owned nothing.
And I had no money,
no credit.
So few ways of getting
any physical capital.
He goes on and on and on.
I won't quote it,
but he continually refers to what he
called his father's old slavery thoughts.
He complains about how his father
never learned how to put up any money,
never learned to save anything. And that
he didn't learn it very well either.
In fact, here's what he says, he
said, my daddy was blindfolded,
didn't look to the
future just throwing him,
I'm sorry for the direct language here,
just throwing his money in a
dead hogs ass and taking shit.
Sorry about that on the video.
But Ned cobb's directness is useful.
It's in the face of
those kinds of obstacles.
It we contain, we call
them that. Nevertheless,
thousands upon thousands of
Friedman embraced in education
and embrace the hope that
literacy could bring.
And let me focus on that just briefly.
At least mired in the
system of sharecropping,
working on halves,
giving half of their crop to the land
owner and half the crop they would keep
and hopefully get cashed,
but then that cash had to be spent down
at the furnishing merchant to get seeds
and get tools and get
food. Excuse me, clothing.
Nevertheless,
in the face of all of this,
one of the things a Freeman most wanted
was this book learning the net carb
never gone.
Well.
We know about slave literacy and
Friedman's literacy is essentially this.
At the end of the civil war,
probably 5% maybe 7% to eight of
the American slaves were literate
by 1870 that had increased
to perhaps 12 to 15%
and
that was due of course to
the Friedman schools to the,
to the Freedmen's bureau schools.
There were tremendous accomplishments
in these Freedmen's bureau schools.
They created over 4,000 of them.
There were some 93 teachers at one time
or another employed and Freeman's bureau
schools up into the 1870s
they had at one point,
slightly more than a quarter million
students in these schools, Freedman,
young and old,
68 72 year old former slaves would sit
down in the same room with eight year
olds and begin to try to
read out of the same reader.
Okay.
And there were in some ways nothing
more threatening to white southerners.
Actually,
there were two things most threatening
to white southerners around which this
southern counterrevolution will be forged.
One was the black school,
black literacy education, the potential
of mobility and the education,
particularly of a black
political leadership class.
And then con.
And then on the other hand,
directly related of course was the
creation of black politics itself.
As we'll see in a moment, one of the
major targets of the Ku Klux Klan,
the knights of the White Chameleon and
all the other imitating groups that
imitated these were black schools.
Dozens and dozens of black schools were
burned to the ground by the Klan between
1868 in the middle of the 1870s.
I want to just read just one little
example of what these schools meant to
people.
Uh,
I love this little letter
because of the assumption, the,
let's call it audacity of hope,
if you'll want, forgive the title.
This comes from a black school
principal whose name was PB Randolph.
He's running a Friedman
school in New Orleans in 1866.
They named it for William Lloyd garrison.
It's called the garrison school.
He has 373,
uh,
pupils and he has seven
teachers, uh, five of them black,
two of them white. And this
was, this was the revolution,
the potential revolution of
reconstruction. And he writes
this letter to himself,
William Lloyd garrison asking for
garrison to help them get what they need.
Just a small excerpt of it.
We are proud of our pupils and
feel you will rejoice with us.
We feel also that you will not take a
miss if we ask a little assistance from
Boston in the shape of apparatus
to illustrate astronomy,
a gyroscope and a microscope,
a numerical frame,
conic sections, cube
root blocks, a magnet,
and such other instruments as will enable
us to fight this battle for our race
against ignorance.
Send us the simplest implements
to teach some science
and a thousands of those such
letters all over the record.
Literacy among blacks
increase to over 80%. Um,
uh, by 1880, I'm sorry,
over 20% by 1880 and probably 25 to 30%.
These things are very difficult to
measure by the turn of the 20th century.
Now you need to know one other thing
here by the 1880 [inaudible] 1890
[inaudible] turn of the 20th century
literacy rates among southern whites.
We're not that much higher.
Yeah.
Remember one thing above all else about
these new economic social arrangements
taking hold from 1866 right on through
the 1870s in the south share cropping
emerge.
This is the argument share
cropping emerged essentially
as a kind of compromise
result of a tug of war between
two kinds of interests.
Blacks wanted autonomy.
They want out of gangs.
They wanted their women out of the field.
They wanted some control
over their economic lives.
White folks,
the owners,
land owners wanted labor to
control a stationary dependent poor
labor force.
Both sides end up embracing tenant farming
sharecropping because it was such a
desperately cash poor society.
Landowners didn't want to rent to
blacks because they knew in the long run
blacks wouldn't get enough
cash to pay the rent.
Blacks realized quickly
they couldn't depend on cash
because there wasn't enough.
They therefore themselves began to resist
wages because they get promised wages
and they wouldn't get paid.
So share cropping this system
that ultimately becomes a
frosty and bargain and a
dead end and a kind of tragic no exit
for the vast majority was nevertheless
something they actually negotiated
and embraced themselves.
No.
Also on the ground in south emerging
out of radical reconstruction
as the southern states were
put under the first reconstruction act
and the subsequent reconstruction acts,
what took place in the south was the
creation of new state governments run by
the Republican party in every former
confederate state, at least at first
all the acts confederate states were
readmitted to the union between 80 and 68
and 1870 Georgia was the last,
but by 1870 all 11 x confederate
states are back in the union,
but they're back in the union. Remember
under that radical reconstruction plan.
Now this story that's set in about
this over the years from the loss cause
ideology of the late 19th century to
the writings of the so called dunning
school of the turn of the 20th
century and early 20th century,
based on the writings of
William h dunning and his many,
many students he trained at Columbia
University was this idea that what what
happened in the south now was essentially
carpet bag rule or rule by bayonet or
rule by blacks.
Now in the history books we've
come to call us for decades,
the myth of carpet bag rule.
This idea that the south was colonized,
taken over by northerners and move
south white northerners and move south,
uh,
plying appealing to exploiting
and manipulating the black
vote to take over the
south to disenfranchise and eliminate
white southerners from their own policy.
Now this much is true in every
former confederate state.
The so called radical constitutions
did manage to create all sorts of new
levels. If you like,
of democracy, small d,
The number of elective offices increase.
It was more direct election,
more direct control for people
in the south had ever seen.
There were more people voting,
more constituencies and more people
holding office. We'll see in a second,
there was more home rule for local
governments than they'd ever experienced
before. These new radical
constitutions. Yes,
indeed had eventually a
fair degree of corruption.
This was the age of spoils and the
kinds of corruption going on in southern
state governments was no difference in
the kinds of corruption going on in many
other places in the country.
But there were many social provisions in
these new constitutions as long as they
lasted.
And they lasted seven,
eight and nine years in some
ex confederate states and
they only lasted three to
three and four years. And others, uh,
for the first time there
were social provisions.
They not only did away
with the black codes,
but they established a certain
degree of equal civil rights.
Some of these new state governments
actually pass the civil rights acts.
Many of the made it the
state's responsibility now
to for the first time in
southern history.
And for that matter,
there wasn't much of it is in the
north either to provide for the sick,
the insane, the disabled,
the poverty stricken.
Yeah.
Above all else, they created public
schools. The first public schools,
the south I'd ever seen.
South Carolina had the first comprehensive
school law of any southern state
passed an 1870 by 1871 they had 32% of
people have school age attending some
1700 public schools in South Carolina,
blacks and whites,
and by 1875 the South Carolina
public schools system,
creative,
other radical republican regime had
50% this is still a rural society and a
society riven with problems
of race and violence is,
we'll see it had 50 probating 75 they
had 50% of school age population of South
Carolina in school with over 3000
teachers paid by public tax money.
Now,
the one thing of course,
that virtually no southern
radical republican southern
regime ever accomplished
was much in the way of any kind of
economic and redistribution of land
redistribution. This is our
classic problem of reconstruction.
How could you advance political liberty,
the right to vote,
the whole office serve on juries.
Run legislatures.
Yeah.
And yet why does economic liberty always,
always,
always lag behind? Now there
were some attempts, however,
let me give you just one little example.
I don't think phone or really
even mentioned to this again,
South Carolina,
which had a black majority of its
legislature for about five years during
reconstruction as well as
a political revolution.
And you can see why white southerners
who were organizing against it,
but the South Carolina
legislature run by blacks,
by blacks and white Republicans,
some of them native born southerners,
some of them from the north created
a South Carolina Land Commission.
They created it in 1868 it actually is
going to last all the way to 1890 on the
books. It, it, it, uh,
it's settled some 5,000
South Carolina families,
black and white on land that the
state purchased or took over,
confiscated in effect,
and then began to sell to its own
citizens on longterm loans at very reduced
interest.
Approximately $225,000 out of $802,000
eventually it could not be accounted for.
There was,
there was some fraud and corruption in
the South Carolina Land Commission about
a quarter of the money that
they actually distributed,
never was accounted for,
but it's extremely important to note here
that at least an attempt was made here
was the,
at least the possibility of
radical reconstruction by
1876 that land commission
in South Carolina by 76 republican still
barely controlled the South Carolina
state government. They're
about to lose it. That year,
[inaudible] 80 76 about 14,000
families had participated,
a total of about 70,000 people,
about 60% black,
40% white in actually buying land.
By 1884 more blacks were
losing land in South Carolina.
However,
then we're buying it.
Yeah.
I'll give you one last little number to
show at least what the possibilities had
been.
In the census of 1890 about 13,000 blacks
in South Carolina owned the farm of
some signs for thousand
of whom had purchased them
through that land commission.
Now we're always talking
about the possibilities,
the experiments of reconstruction.
What if, what if, what if,
what if it had been more enforcement?
What has it been more military occupation?
What if,
what if the Klan and its
imitators had truly been crushed?
All the other crushed this kind of land
commission is one example among others
of the kinds of efforts that could have
flourished.
Now
in those state governments in the south,
you had for the first time in American
history and in a kind of a explosion of
political activity,
you had black elected officials,
approximately 2000 African Americans
in the southern states served in state
legislatures and state government
and executive positions.
And ultimately in the U S Congress,
16 African Americans from x confederate
states were elected to the u s Congress
to,
to the u s senate,
Hiram revels from Mississippi being the
first black senator in American history.
And how many times do you hear in
our political culture today? Uh,
the first black since reconstruction,
the first this since reconstruction,
the first of that,
the first black governor
since reconstruction was
Doug Wilder in Virginia.
The first this and the first
that since reconstruction,
it's because there was this explosion
of black political activity for a short
period of time,
decade really until the lights went out.
Yeah,
of the 1000 delegates to constitutional
writing conventions in 1868 69 when
these new state governments were created
of about the thousand delegates that
participated in writing those new
constitution, 268 of them were blind.
About 680 African Americans served in
the lower houses of state governments
during reconstruction for presided as
speakers of those houses that were 112
African Americans and served in
state senates during reconstruction.
There were at least 41 black sheriffs
somewhere in one of the 11 x confederate
states. There were five black mayors
of southern cities for awhile.
There were 145 blacks is heard on
city councils and so on and so on.
Now
this is the heart of the
myth of carpet bag rule.
The claim against these people in the
south, at least in the white south,
was always they were not prepared.
They were ignorant.
All they did is sit around eating
chicken bones and spitting in the Gold's
platoons that they
bought with public money.
And if you've ever seen birth of a nation,
a DW Griffith's,
a white supremacist epic of 1915 he
plays out that scene at great length of,
of the black politicians
in state legislatures would
their boots up on tables,
literally chewing on chicken bones and
spitting in this platoons and laughing
and playing happy Darcie
until the cows come home.
Yeah.
There were corrupt black politicians and
there were a corrupt white politicians.
I don't really have time to go into all
the great biographical stories of the
Robert Smalls is and the John Roy Robert
smalls as a South Carolina and the John
Roy Lynch's of Mississippi and,
and so many others who,
many of whom were former slaves,
all the,
some of them had been free before
the war by their own purchase,
by manumission mission, by other means.
Some of them, only a small percentage.
We're northern born blacks who moved
south like Hiram revels and eventually got
himself elected to the Senate.
By the way, just recently,
well,
I guess it was buddy years ago when the
Republicans had control of the Senate,
they put up a portrait for the
first time of Hiram revels.
Our Modern Republican party wanted
to claim him. He wasn't Republican.
So are they by name?
Uh,
but anyway there is now today
a portrait of Hiram revels.
It took a century more to get it there,
but he's finally up in the u s senate,
his picture.
Now, the other side of this
myth of carpet bag rule,
and I want to be a
little speedy about this,
but it's also very important
this again this the story,
the deep myth that set into
American culture for generations,
is it all these reconstruction governments
really where we're a bunch of Yankees
who came south,
got themselves elected with black votes
and ran these governments and oppressive
white southerners.
So who were these carpetbaggers so-called
the term got into our language and now
today anybody who grows up in one state
but somehow moves to another and tries
to get elected as Hillary
Clinton did in New York.
And there are plenty of other example is
labeled a carpet bagger at least for 10
years or so until she's lived there long
enough and gets reelected and I guess I
guess you got to get reelected
before you no longer a carpet bagger.
What many of these northern isn't
one south were former union soldiers.
Most of them went before 1867 and 68
before these radical republican regimes
were put in place.
They want to become farmers.
They went to because of the land was
so cheap and some of them one because I
liked the climate,
there were New Hampshire rights,
so went to Mississippi
because it was warm.
Some carpet baggers were industrialists,
investors. They saw the south.
Now is the place to invest.
It obviously was,
it was prostate and it needed money.
Some are federal agents, Freedmen's
bureau agents and stayed and lived there.
Many were teachers,
some of them stayed and lived if
they survive and weren't killed.
Some were political opportunists
and some were adventurers.
A ne'er do wells and I'll
never forget as long as I live.
One of the best friends I have in the
world is a Methodist minister in Chicago
who grew up in Mississippi and east Texas.
Gene Winkler and a positively brought,
he's one of the best read
human beings I've ever known.
He worries more about
the civil war than I do.
I used to actually ask him
what I should be reading.
His real job was being a minister,
but he spent most of his time reading
and he was one of the most politically
radical people I've ever known.
I mean,
he was still trying to be a
socialist during Reaganism.
But one day I asked gene as gene,
why do you keep that picture of
stonewall Jackson and Robert E. Lee?
And the corner of your
office said, you know what,
I'm not exactly sure,
but it's probably because carpet
baggers killed my great granddaddy.
I don't think he said,
God damn carpet baggers.
He's a good Methodist carpet baggers.
Killed my great granddaddy.
I said, Whoa, okay.
Like so many southerners,
he was a complicated mixture of memories.
Uh, and, uh, well enough on gene.
I actually got the thrill,
uh,
some years ago to write an
essay epilogue to Fitz Brundage,
his book of essays called where these
memories grow about southern memory.
And I opened the piece
with that very story.
I was always worried about how
gene was going to interpret it.
Any thank God liked it, I think. Anyway,
at no time did carpet baggers ever
make up anywhere near a majority of any
southern legislature
in the x confederate states.
Their goals tended to be financial,
economic and to some extent political.
And then there's this other
kind of southerner. Yeah.
The white indigenous southern or the
native born white southerner known to
history of course is scalawags
who joined the republican part.
Yeah.
Who became part of these reconstruction
regimes who said give up the past,
give up the old cars.
And they often became the object of the
iron and the hatred and the violence
of white vigilante groups
as readily as anyone else.
Now
what was the scale away?
Uh,
well let me tell you the
ways. Hold on. Sorry.
We're good. Me got it. Now.
Galloway Egg. So a scallywag is,
by the way, our runty little horse.
That's actually what it means. If you
look it up, it's a runty little horse.
I kind of useless a little horse.
It doesn't work very well for you.
Just gets in the way,
stinks and smells and doesn't pay his way
are scallywag is the local leper of
the community. Wrote a Tuscaloosa,
Alabama newspaper editor in
1869 unlike the carpet bagger,
he is native,
which is so much the worse.
Once he was respected in his circle,
his head was level and we would look his
name and he would look as neighbor in
the face.
Now possessed of the itch of office
and the salt room of radicalism.
He is a mangy dogs.
Slinking the alleys haunting
the governor's office
defiling with tobacco juice,
the steps of the capitol stretching his
lazy carcass in the sun on the square or
the benches of the mayor's court.
That's relatively direct.
Scalawags were considered,
in other words, turncoats.
Now they had a variety of social
backgrounds, some worth sort of former.
Nobody's, but most of them were actually
quite prominent people like the wartime
confederate. And governor of
Georgia Josephy Brown who said,
give up the cars and joined the
Republican Party after the war.
Perhaps the most famous of all,
James Longstreet Lee's second in command.
In the last two years of the war,
long streets of Georgia moved out to
Louisiana after the war embraced the
Republican Party,
said the war had settled something
and the southerners had to face it.
And he became a railroad president and
he even for awhile commanded US troops in
Louisiana who tried to kill off the clan.
There are many, many other examples. Um,
there's James settle of North
Carolina. He's one of my favorites. Um,
and these were fascinating
people. Um, courageous people.
A saddle of North Carolina had been
a member of the confederate congress.
He'd been a big player in confederate
politics in North Carolina.
But after the war,
he said this,
the war had brought a general breaking up.
He said of old ideas taking a
new start in the world. We are,
if we are ever to have
prosperity and any concluded,
I tell you,
Yankees and Yankee notions are
just what we want in this country.
Now we want their capital to build
factories in workshops and railroads.
We want their intelligence,
their energy and enterprise to operate
factories and to teach us how to do it.
Settle, nearly was killed
for his views, his actions,
his political actions in
particular or many other examples.
Uh, Amos t Ackerman and
Georgia, uh, among others.
Look up him and phoner.
Uh, if you like. Now
I guess the only other thing I want to
say about that is there were a carpet bag
governors,
there were northern born Republicans who
ended up governors of southern states.
Several of them. There were northern born
members of southern state legislatures,
some black,
some white,
and they became
many instances the most ready,
um, targets of what was to come. No.
Ah,
there we are.
I don't know how well you
can see this painting.
I'll try to blow it up.
It doesn't have a date on it,
unfortunately. Uh, yeah.
I need to figure that out.
It is entitled Disfranchisement,
which is an interesting title.
If you can see on the right, you can
see about every kind of a image of a,
of a, of a bitter, angry Hayden,
the eyes southerner,
some sitting on the Canon,
others in Ku Klux Klan robes and masks.
All of them.
Of course looking at
the lone black Friedman.
Go on your first look. It almost looks
like he's holding a machete, but he's not.
He's holding a voting role
now
the southern white counterrevolution
the move towards southern redemption,
which simply means of course the dumber,
the southern Democratic Party taking
back control of their states between 1870
and 1876
is rooted in their hatred there resentment
of the rise of black political and
economic independence.
Now,
but first of all,
go with me back to Washington and then
we'll end at least today back on the
ground in the south and try to understand
where some of this violence is coming
from.
The 15th Amendment Task Congress,
the 15th now pass Congress
in the spring,
late spring of 1869
okay.
It's right after you listen to it.
As grant is inaugurated,
president elected in the fall
and inaugurated in the spring
by 1868 11 of the 21 northern states
still denied the right to vote to blacks.
You'll remember Republican's are stepping
around this question of black suffrage
in the north,
but they want to plant it into the south,
but the trick was what kind
of amendment would it be?
This is the great voting rights amendment.
Okay.
They went through three versions of,
of the 15th Amendment,
looked this up and phone.
Make sure you understand this.
They went through three versions in the
debate in Congress as to what kind of
voting rights amendment to put in
the constitution. The first version,
and they went from most
conservative to most radical.
The first version for bade states the
right to deny suffrage on grounds of race,
color,
or previous condition of servitude.
That's all it said.
That's the most conservative version.
The second version would have four bay,
four bades states to impose literacy
property or Nativity qualifications.
In other words,
that whole array of qualifications,
tests that will ultimately be used all
over the south to prevent black folk from
voting and to some extent poor white folk.
And then it was a third version was
simply would have affirms simply that all
male citizens 21 years of age and
older had the right to vote, period.
Now they debated and debated,
but the one they passed of course was
the first one, the most conservative,
the one that made absolutely no mention
of the possibility of qualifications
test.
And so the 15th amendment has two kinds
of of of impact to great importance is
if you want. One is that it was passed
at all and it's hugely important.
But the other of course is it was
a very conservative compromise.
The men left the door open to all kinds
of machinations over time in states at
the local level about qualifications
to vote.
It passed the House of Representatives
in March,
it finally was ratified by two thirds
of the state legislatures in the United
States.
A full year later in the spring of
1870 and many people now looked at the
situation in the country a
year into grants presidency.
The man, the Republican who
said, let us have peace.
You've got the 13th
amendment abolishing slavery.
You've got the 14th amendment establishing
the citizenship rights and equal
protection before the law.
At least the beginnings of this
fledgling thing called civil rights.
You've got the
reconstruction acts in place.
Southern states have all been
brought back into the union. By 1870.
Georgia was still being
sort of weirdly adjudicated,
but it finally was brought back in in
1870 and now comes the voting rights act.
And throughout the
history of, of modern, uh,
know modern political philosophy
and modern political history.
The idea was that the vote,
you know,
it was the essence of democracy.
And so once you've given
people the vote on some level,
what else could you possibly do?
Republicans now say to themselves that
they have established the principle,
oh,
would that the head of guaranteed rights
and that they could go no further.
One Republican wrote to another
after voting for this, he said,
this is the last great point that remains
to be settled from the issues of the
war and Horace Greeley famously in
his New York Herald Tribune in April,
1870 after the ratification of the 15th
Amendment said quote let us have done
with reconstruction, was
the opening line of, of,
of under a big headline a lot of
us have done with reconstruction.
The country is tired and sick of it.
Let us have peace.
It's over.
It's done.
Said official Republican
Party people to themselves.
Of course,
the white south for two years already
through it's rising and growing Democratic
Party and its violent
militant wings is saying,
you bet reconstruction is over.
Let us show you the ways.
Now
I'm actually going to save the violence
story for an entire lecture on its own.
Uh, the clan, it's many actions,
examples through the Colfax massacre
at least of 1873 for next Tuesday.
But let me leave you with this.
What happens now?
What is already happening now in the
first grant administration by 1870 is what
we might simply call,
it's the waning of radicalism.
It's the waning of that,
that civic vision, his phone,
or calls it in your book of the
radical Republicans ideology.
And what was that vision phone
or lays it all out for you.
He said the radical Republicans had
an essential ideological vision.
On the one hand, it was
unionism. On the other hand,
it was routed to some extent and trying
to create racial equality because the
ward necessitated it
and forced it on them.
They therefore were,
were believers in this idea of guaranteed
rights within the constitution.
And last but not least,
they were believers in positive activists,
central government.
And you put those three or four principals
together and you've got the package
that was the civic vision
of the radical Republicans.
But the problem is that vision
is now going to crumble, um,
as fast, almost as fast as it
ever came into existence. In fact,
it's going to crumble faster than
it ever came in to existence.
I want to leave you with this.
It's not just going to crumble because
Republicans are sort of give up the game
and it's not going to just crumble
because that is Stevens dies and Charles
Sumner is out of the way and radicals
don't really run this party underground
anymore.
It's going to crumble because of the
most widespread use of political violence
in American history. We'll return
to this question next Tuesday bid.
Let me leave you with this.
There is no African American writer and
some white writers worth their salt from
the 1870s and eighties right on through,
into well into the 20th century who could
ever avert their eyes from this story.
This is a passage from James Weldon.
Johnson is the autobiography
of an ex colored man.
If you've ever read that
wonderful 1912 novel,
you'll know it's the story of a
black man is passing for white,
but because he's passing in the south,
he gets to see things that
people don't know he's seen.
And of course the book ends is so many
books did in this time with a lynching.
This is x colored man who doesn't have
any other name describing what he sees.
A railroad tie was sunk into the ground.
The rope was removed,
and a chain Broughton securely coiled
around the victim and the stake there.
He stood a man only informing stature.
His eyes were full and vacant,
indicating not a single ray of thought.
Fuel was brought from everywhere.
Oil,
the torch,
the flames crouched for an instant as
though to gather strength then leaped up
as high as the victim's
head. He squirmed, he rides,
he strained at his chains,
then gave out cries and groans
that I show always here.
His eyes bulging from their sockets,
roll from side to side,
appealing in vain for help.
I was fixed to the spot where I stood
powerless to take my eyes from what I did
not want to see.
We have never wanted to see what really
happened in the south and the 1870s but
we'll try.